russian world 15 charming schools
how do you like such a russian world
[music]
maria klein klein camp for today
to lose crops aviation
cannon artillery
jet salvo system remember
mariupol appreciate that it has not
become a century protect I have become goin and I need
Chekhov May 3 I close all of ukraine try for
I wouldn’t wake up Mariupol, I will be Ukraine
[music]
today we received confirmation
from the Russian Federation from the Ministry of
Defense of the Russian Federation that the passage
from Mariupol, the city of Zaporozhye, the Dnieper thief,
is safe, with such signs, with the
support of the Red Cross, we had to
go in the direction  the city of
Zaporozhye, unfortunately, at the
moment when we were ready
, the shelling of the regular army of the
Russian Federation began along the corridor along
which we were supposed to move
.  on
witches and you are not him they took away a
lot of their children in our rivers we knew  and
[music]
here it is the courtyard of the
maternity hospital courtyard of the hospital
[music]
after all, watering and Malyukov
shelling a
new house
[music]